i went undercover for a weight loss
anti-bloating diet program to show you
all the red flags and i'm a spill of tea
[Music]
[Applause]
so
hear me out here i get a lot of dms and
i actually read most of them and respond
to quite a few but a few weeks ago a
number of people sent me an instagram
link to a diet program that was
promising to eliminate bloating ibs and
cause significant weight loss in just a
few short weeks sure
i looked through the instagram account
and saw a bunch of typical before and
after photos then i went to the website
to learn a little bit more about what
the program actually was all about
interestingly there were lots more
photos and lots of testimonials but not
much else in terms of what the diet
entailed the qualifications of the
creators or even the price so i was like
[Music]
this is shady as
but obviously i want to know more so i
booked one of their onboarding calls to
learn more but basically my spidey sense
was right that band's an imposter and
they were just trying to sell me on one
of their programs on the spot so in
today's video i'm gonna share what i
experienced during that onboarding call
and the big red flags that i want you
guys all to avoid if you're ever
considering trying out one of these
online wellness programs but first let
me tell you about my sponsor care of
between my digestive concerns sleep
stress and general health your girl
takes a lot of pills but i am honestly a
big proponent of supplements if they
help you achieve better food freedom by
allowing you to enjoy the foods you love
so i was really excited to try care of
which is a supplement subscription
service that ships high quality vitamins
straight to your door every month the
way it works is that you take a
personalized quiz about your health
goals and it gives you unique
recommendations based on those answers
my quiz recommended vitamin d probiotic
blend protein powder magnesium and
rhodiola as well as their gut check
quick sticks for on the go this was
largely to address some of my digestive
struggles and ibs as well as my goal to
improve my long-term sleep and stress
concerns i've only started using the
service but it really does make it so
much easier to be able to get all the
supplements that you need in one easy
place especially because i don't even
have to leave home to get them and as a
dietitian i love that care of
supplements are third party tested and
backed by the latest science which you
all know is really important to me and
when your goals or needs change it's
easy to update your quiz and get new
recommendations sent your way so if
you're looking to start a supplement
routine or update your current one take
care of quiz to find out what's
recommended for you and you can check
out the link in my description and use
my promo code abby sharp to get 50 off
of your first order and a very quick
disclaimer here the purpose of this
video is obviously not to expose this
program or this coach so i'm bleeping
out names altering his voice and i'm
also not going to respond to comments on
what this program actually is let's keep
it respectful and educational also a
heads up this interview has been edited
for brevity so you're not really going
to understand the full context of
everything that was said but that's why
the point of this video is not to
critique or criticize this particular
program it is just to share with you
some specific verbiage or language or
words that are often used in some of
these wellness course sales funnels i
want to focus on some of the problematic
red flags at large and that way you can
apply these no matter what kind of
program you run into online any audio
that you hear is really just to help you
understand some examples and the
verbiage that is often used to sell
programs like this and of course don't
forget to subscribe to this channel and
ring that little bell and don't forget
to follow me over on instagram and tick
tock all right folks let's get into it
red flag number one they don't screen
for eating disorders when giving
restrictive diet advice i've discussed
this red flag in my new review right
here but i basically mentioned that it's
pretty problematic to be prescribing a
restrictive weight loss diet and then in
the same breath to be promising to heal
your relationship with food we hear this
all the time in a lot of these kind of
new world diet plans and i'm not saying
that these two things cannot exist at
the same time or happen concurrently but
i am saying that this can be very
dangerous territory without a very
skilled well-trained team
generally speaking for the masses
restrictive diets often just shift the
ed mindset from worrying about one bad
food or component of food to another so
they might tell you that you don't need
to count calories but now instead you
just need to cut out 20 different foods
to fix your digestion respectfully i
would say that this is much less likely
to fix your digestion as it is to just
further distract you from getting the
help that you actually need and
sometimes the help that you need is to
be told to no longer diet and when i
specifically asked about this i got a
roundabout response when i was a
teenager and like in my early 20s had an
eating disorder um is this program still
appropriate for folks who have like had
eating disorders or have like
probably long-term kind of struggles
with their relationship with food as far
as like really supporting you with with
the development of
your relationship with food
we can absolutely do that like have you
people who already have like long
histories with
problems with like you know having a a
challenging relationship with food later
like earlier on in life when they have
to obviously like it seems sounds like
and i don't know what your the diet
protocol is but it sounds like there's a
bunch of foods that i've gotta cut out
is that like have you seen people
get worse in terms of their eating
disorder or anything like that in your
program
yeah so i haven't seen anyone get worse
we've never had any like harsh reviews
we were like ouch so in this specific
program there might be a screening down
the road i don't know i didn't get that
far maybe one day we'll find out but it
certainly was never mentioned at all on
the onboarding call as a way to really
determine if the program was right for
me which was apparently the purpose of
the onboarding call and honestly anyone
trained in evidence-based eating
disorder support would know that a diet
that requires you to cut out a bunch of
foods is often not right for anyone with
a history of eds and if it is still to
be used it needs to be done so with very
careful supervision and professional
support and speaking of professional
support the next big red flag is when
the program is run by self-taught gurus
and not credible evidence-based
professionals i should have hung up when
i heard the guy say
this is years of rigorous self-study and
self-experiment and we've had about 400
people come through now to have amazing
results personally my personal opinion
is you know self-study and
self-education is pretty important no
there's a huge difference between
continuing education through verified
evidence-based channels as we do as
dietitians and doctors do when we go to
conferences or upgrade our specialty
training no special training just via
the fight i'm ready to back up
everything i'm saying and i'm through
talking but
self-education can be really dangerous
especially in the digital age there is
no shortage of conspiracy bull on the
internet and if you want to believe
something you will absolutely have no
trouble finding a website or a blog or a
facebook group that confirms and
validates those beliefs do you maybe see
a problem with what you've done
thanks to social media everyone is a
nutrition expert but most of the public
have no clue what to look for when
seeking out a legitimate source so look
very carefully at those qualifications
and choose a course taught by someone
with validated evidence-based education
not just a weekend self-study course or
personal experience and that brings me
to my next red flag folks i want you to
run for the hills when the only evidence
of success is anecdotal the power of
anecdotal evidence or storytelling is
profound anecdotal evidence and
testimonies are often a lot more
persuasive than actual research because
they have these digestible sound bites
that are communicated with passion and
sensationalism in a way that can cause
them to more easily go viral compared
with actual scientific non-sexy research
testimonies also come from real people
and it's way easier to identify with a
real person than a more abstract
statistical reality but we don't do
research on a sample size of one for a
reason it's riddled with cognitive bias
and confounders and it's not at all
replicable it's not actual science
here's an example of what i mean and
jacqueline at the time you know she had
tried absolutely everything she can't
figure out why her bloating why her acid
reflux
why these things constipation will not
go away and just doing what pretty much
and i had found and had worked on over
time within 30 days i mean that thing it
was like a blast in the past of course
we all want a happy ever after story
like this but a we actually don't have
proof that any of these stories that we
hear online or through word of mouth are
actually true and b
if they were true which of course we
would hope that they are what we're
missing out on is everything else going
on what else was happening in this one
person's life that could have
contributed to an improvement in
symptoms aside from whatever 30-day diet
they tried i mean even the placebo
effect could be a more likely cause than
the unique characteristics of any one
diet or cleanse and that brings me to
another flag when they don't disclose
what you have to do or eat until you buy
the program okay so i never even thought
of this as a red flag until i did this
program onboarding call and i was
shocked by how cryptic it all felt this
program legit blanked out parts of the
testimonies that had any reference to
the diet that they were on on their
website and when i called them out for
it i was told
well we can't really give away our
secret sauce before you pay for the
program take a listen i guess my first
question is like why isn't that that
information given because obviously that
like if it's something that can't be
done from the get-go then i kind of
would have would want to know that you
know i i saw in one of the questions
they asked do you eat red meat uh
because if you don't then it's not a
good fit so i mean is this like a
carnivore diet is it like a full-on like
carnivore keto diet um it just felt like
weird that that information wasn't even
shared at all i mean part of the reason
why we don't share it because because we
have people invest in the opportunity to
learn it and to encourage the
information um so we wouldn't like to
you know put out our cure not cure but
you know healing protocol out there
really the answer is none of the above i
mean we do start off with definitely
eliminating some foods which i can talk
to you about this is more than a red
flag my friends this is false
advertising and it's dangerous as
you wouldn't go to a health care
practitioner who made you pay for the
unknown service before they would
disclose if they were going to do like
physiotherapy or massage on you you
wouldn't sign a waiver for a surgery and
not know if they were going to be
amputating a limb or like taking out a
tooth i'm in i'm out i quit whose
kidneys are these it's called informed
consent and it is so irresponsible to
sell anyone on something that they
really know nothing about yikes moving
on to red flag number five you have to
cut out entire food groups so this
program proudly advertised that you
don't need to count calories fast or
take any expensive supplements or shakes
great but then is it because then i
instantly knew it would be a strict
elimination diet i instantly knew it
would be pretty miserable and the
problem with elimination diet programs
for the masses like this is that they
usually can only do more harm than good
an elimination diet is always a risk
benefit situation so it should only ever
be performed under the individual
supervision of a registered dietitian
who can custom tailor it to you based on
your unique triggers and needs cutting
out foods that you specifically don't
need to cut out risks nutritional
deficiencies disordered eating and
damage to the gut microbiome now as far
as like other food groups well you know
some some of the more obvious foods
we'll be taking to break from will be
things like alcohol uh fried sugar
supplied carbs um as far as some not so
obvious foods would be taking the break
from those will be things like fiber in
the beginning and uh the protocol really
is just because
this is what works to get the results
that people want yeah that's a hard pass
for me dog moving on another big no-no
is when the program discredits or
fear-mongers mainstream healthcare as
being a shill for big pharma let's take
a listen um but as far as like you know
doctors they're not even taught anything
on nutrition um i have two pregnant
authors at least in the states here and
it's really really sad um but you know
it's all for the push of big farm up
listen the traditional western
healthcare system isn't the only tool we
have in our toolbox and for a lot of
folks with super complicated nutrition
or digestive concerns going to your gp
is often just not going to get you all
of the symptom relief that you might
want or need and that's because doctors
have to know a fair bit about a lot of
different areas of practice so it's
often not possible for them to dive deep
enough into some of these really super
nuanced cases it is not because they're
money hungry shills who will prescribe
or push anything to make a buck that is
fear-mongering bull and it discredits
the millions of hard-working caring
health care professionals who truly do
want the best for you and sometimes the
best for you is pharmaceuticals
sometimes it's a more natural approach
and a lot of the times it's a
combination of both and on that note
another big red flag is when a sales
program positions itself as the secret
solution that mainstream healthcare
doesn't want you to know
shocking hang on folks you are not going
to believe this this is a common tactic
in the wellness space and it's honestly
toxic as
this conspiracy theory has really got to
stop do you really think that millions
of healthcare workers around the world
have like banded together in a secret
society to stop the proliferation of
knowledge that would universally help
lives no because all of those healthcare
workers know that there is no universal
secret sauce to health it is highly
individual and no one program would ever
fix everyone in the world if we had a
simple universal cure for obesity cancer
ibs you name it we would absolutely know
it by now listen to this well i again
like it hasn't been very transparent for
me in terms of like what what it's gonna
entail like it's kind of cryptic which
is a little scary for me and i can eat
red meat but i don't eat red meat very
often like
for environmental reasons for health
reasons um it's expensive i have this
like sense that this is like a this
might must be some kind of carnivore
diet cleanse you know as far as like
environmental doctors of red meat again
there is a lot of misinformation out
there and we do there's a real law of
every education um
what kind of underground cherry-picked
data are you drawing on to convince me
to only eat red meat like that is
nutritional gas lighting as far as i'm
concerned like i said before there is a
niche pool of evidence of varying
degrees of quality for virtually
anything you want to prove or disprove
you want to confirm that water isn't wet
there's probably a reddit thread
somewhere for you real science isn't a
secret it's the antithesis of secrecy
it's the proliferation of knowledge with
the greatest level of control and
precision possible it's not perfect but
it's certainly better than an instagram
influencer who knows how to google red
flag number eight it promises instant
success without any mention of long-term
results so this conversation says it all
your participants in like a couple years
down the road or anything like that that
would give you any insight onto how
like how they've maintained their weight
loss or how they've maintained their
symptom remission
[Music]
i can think of it's been about nine
weeks now so not like you know one or
two years i think that's a great idea to
highlight that and to reach out to those
past clients yeah
nine weeks is not long term and it's
also in their best interest not to track
long-term results when those results
would probably not be in their favor oh
hell no this program for example was
described at times as like a reset and i
was told that i could incorporate the
off-limit foods back into my life after
the short-lived diet how could we
not expect any weight loss or symptom
improvements to regress when we just go
back to real life
and that brings me to red flag number
nine it insists that their way is the
way to see results take a listen your
budget changes um i can tell you for
sure that this is the way to really try
and get rid of bloating and the
constipation and really sibo we've had a
lot of people come into placebo um and a
lot of people reversed it the incredible
thing about human bodies is that there
is no one-size-fits-all for anything
when we're talking about bloating we
need to know the cause of the bloating
in order to properly treat it and while
anyone can likely lose weight in a
calorie deficit keeping it off will
really depend on the person and how well
that lifestyle or diet aligns with their
lifestyle there is no one way to see
results hard stop so i was straight up
with this guy at the end of the call i
mean this program was obviously not for
me and even though it was a really
expensive program i told him that it
wasn't a price objection per se but that
it didn't seem right to commit to a
program without knowing what i was
committing to so hopefully he gets that
feedback from more than just me and they
actually take it to heart that unlike
all the other red flags i stated as well
but on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if there's
anything else you want to see me review
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]